[Music]
today's question comes from marissa in
michigan i'm 28 years old and currently
at the end of what has been a very long
and tiring phd program as they
most of them are my goal has been to
stay in academia where i could teach and
do research but i discovered along the
way that this is not the path for me for
a variety of reasons i've lived very
frugally and worked on the side so i
have no debt in 75 000 in savings and
investments wow way to go marissa
i've worked over 70 hours a week for the
last six years and i'm exhausted i've
lost interest in any work to related to
what i've studied and i dread entering
the workforce only to do more of the
work i've grown to despise
what should i do wow
there's a whole lot here i'm going to
simplify this john i know you'll add to
this but i would start with because of
your financial uh i would call it
freedom
i think it would be good for you to go
do some job just any job forget and i'm
the guy that's always pushing people to
find their purpose and find that dream
job which is simply about using what you
do best to do work you love that
produces results that matter
because you're so fried marissa on this
type of work i think you go try
something totally different and just if
it's just covering the basics the bills
but you've always been intrigued by it
and you're just going i want to do this
work because i think it'd be kind of
neat kind of fun or i just want to help
these people and get a paycheck i keep
it really simple and i think that's the
first step of kind of coming off of this
this this uh deep fryer we use in the
deep south where we throw anything in
and it's just hot burning grease and
it's bubbling and i think she's been in
that so long then i would
make sure i start
re-examining what caused me to feel
fried and lose it i think there's a
whole lot of circumstances john that we
can't get to because this is an email
question but i would examine do i love
the work still if i wasn't in that
cauldron that boiling cauldron of
pressure maybe some toxicity a whole lot
here we don't know about
and the way i would do that is by myself
i'd spend some time just getting alone
under a tree uh in front of a lake quiet
and go
why did i love the work originally
and if i removed all the negative yuck
would i still love the work and then the
third step i would say is and this is
tactical you can help out on the
emotional advice and everything else but
i'd get with some people who
do that work
and they're really fulfilled and very
happy yeah and i just spent some time
talking to them and go what's your
environment like
and i would do all of that to see if the
heart is telling us it's time to move to
something totally different because it
could be
or the heart's just damaged and it's
wounded that that's my quick take yeah
and and anybody who's finishing i love
like the deep fryer and who's coming out
deep fryer you're getting done with the
phd program it's been very long oh my
god
you should be burned out i can't only
i'm fairly certain that my wife likes me
on most days and my kids
and there are some days when she says
i need to go away today yeah i need to
go away for a couple of days right so
just because you need a break i love
that idea just go get a job go get a job
and it's almost like a palette cleanser
yeah go put your head into something and
you can because you've worked really
hard yeah and
man you were you were dead on working in
academia at a big research one
institution is different from a teaching
college different from a faith-based
school from a community college do you
hate teaching do you hate students do
you hate research do you hate chemistry
like get clear and you can only get
clear when you've got some space that's
exactly yeah just back out a little bit
but just because you're fried doesn't
mean you're crazy it doesn't mean you
have chemistry right or editing or
whatever you got your phd in yeah it may
just be you're exhausted yeah yeah and
again i've taken so many calls from
teachers who thought at the start of the
phone call ken they started off by
saying ken i need to get out of teaching
i have no career what to go to help and
when we dig in we find that they're our
teacher they're part of the teacher
they're put on this planet to instruct
if we're going to make it simple and now
we've got to find a different
environment because maybe the
environment you're in for reasons that
they go through isn't the best and they
go oh it's not but they find well public
school environment isn't for me but
community college i would love it or
trade school or go to the corporate
world and be a trainer which is an
instructor so uh
it's tough man yeah because it's so hard
to see clearly john when you're just
trying to keep your nose above the water
yeah sometimes i imagine a doctor it
feels like that
like you're just the waters up here yeah
and as hard as she's been working on the
side oh on top of everything else that's
right yeah
well we appreciate the questions